aha
the beloved airfryer
not only does it make lovely crispy
fries
but it just saves so much time with very
little effort what's up everybody zacky
here from geek culture with another
fantastic video bringing all things that
is good and delicious with this bad boy
the philips airfryer double xl this
spaceship looking thingy majiggy not
only makes your store-bought finger food
delicious but with all that extra space
you can actually fit a whole chicken in
it
no lie guys
no lie
yes a whole chicken thanks to its 7.3
liter basket capacity
essentially cooking a family size meal
gets a whole lot easier with this huge
humongous airfryer we are talking about
1.4 kilograms of fries here that's a lot
of fries so whether you're having a
party or cooking for your family this is
basically an all-in-one solution for
whipping up healthier meals so that's
what we're gonna do we're gonna put this
baby to the test as well as to go
through some of its neat little features
so that you can decide whether this
airfryer is for you we're gonna do fries
mushrooms fish as well as a whole
chicken all simple lazy geek recipes
that you can do yourself at home it's
the 21st century my dudes and dudettes
there's no reason you need pots and pans
anymore so before we get cooking let's
check out some of his nitty gritty
details
first of all this airfryer just looks
great looks amazing with this sleek
glossy deep black overall with copper
accents
the buttons and the handle as well as a
knob over here yeah the overall design
just makes it look like it can fit in
any kitchen one thing to note though
this airfryer is humongous it's 43
centimeters long
32 centimeters in depth and 31
centimeters in height so do keep in mind
that you will need some tablespace if
you haven't already not to mention it's
quite hefty as well weighing about eight
kilograms so with the philips airfryer
double xl what you get is six buttons on
the interface panel
the first button is a stay warm or
reheat button
second one you can save your current
settings as your favorite the airfryer
also allows you to set in manual mode
the temperature and the timer function
as well as a go back to the menu button
and of course the power button on top of
that with the turn knob you have five
prefix programs which allows you to cook
frozen fries raw meat and even fish so
there's some cool tech behind this air
fryer it has this cool thing called the
smart sensing technology that
automatically adjusts the time and
temperature
for the perfect results every time and
with its instant heat and rapid airflow
technology the food you cook will be 1.5
times faster than your typical toaster
oven so with that said let's get to
cooking some fries
yeah so what we got here is a bag of
fries
we're gonna pretty much throw about half
the bag
let's just do that that should be enough
for us for every morning so in terms of
ergonomics the philips airfryer double
xl uses a rating system so you can
simply slide in slide out the handle is
detachable so you can actually load your
fries and put it in yeah let's load this
in
all we need to do is press
the
frozen fries
picture over here on the display and
go
and now we wait
so with the instant heat and rapid
airflow technology there's no need for
you to actually preheat your air fryer
just simply plug and play
load your fries in or load whatever
you're cooking in
and just wait so another great feature
about this philips airfryer double xl is
this cool wall exterior it also has feet
at the bottom so
it doesn't matter what surface you're
going to work on
it won't burn your table or your
countertop
so yeah
not at all
amazing guys
um so our fries are not just about done
but you can hear it's beeping
[Music]
means that it's time to take it out and
give it a shake so
whoa wheel
out
good night
oops
sorry so i'll give you a nice shaky
shaker
put it back into the airfryer and
go
so it looks like our fries is ready
let's take a look and how it looks like
wow
kind of
nice and
almost golden brown
but is it crispy oh
it's like oven baked fries
nice and what you want to do is add a
sprinkling of salt
kind of like my fries salty
and just a dabble of all-purpose
seasoning i'm using cajun so
just sprinkle all of it there
yeah
don't mind the mess
and let's just have a taste test
[Music]
oh
crispy on outside
fluffy inside
it's kind of like oven fries
you know it's not as crispy as it was if
you're gonna deep fry them but you know
if you're looking for a healthy option
pretty damn good
so why not
let me bring in the guests and see
whether
they like this rise so let's have a
things and uh
see where it's going let's go
right maybe if we add a dip or something
right yep
i can do this
so it's good yeah
all right so the next thing we're gonna
do right here is start we got some
broccoli florets
because if you haven't tried
air fried broccoli man you guys are in
for a treat
so
put
some fried broccoli
and you know vegetables is cool man eat
the vegetables
all right you know what let's just dump
the whole bag
why not
and just snap in
and let's just put it again
on
frozen fry settings and see how it goes
yeah stay tuned
and the broccoli doesn't take long to
cook so just check it if everything is
nice and brown
on the floor itself nice and kind of
crispy
then it's time to serve your
broccoli
nice
what i like to do is sprinkle a little
bit of salt just with everything
salt save slice
all right as you can see it's nice and
crisp
like uh like if you put it on a barbecue
stove it will kind of look like this
except less oily really great so
let's try it myself
[Music]
kind of makes broccoli
a very little different yeah it kind of
feels like
like outside in a barbecue friends
and instead of sausages you're like hey
look i brought some broccoli he's gonna
drink the fire
yeah but does it work oh yeah yeah
yeah but i think it would
be great if uh if you toss in more salt
it's kind of liking a bit of tang yeah
uh i like that smoky aftertaste though
yeah very nice
kind of reminds me of
i'm sure
seaweed
with seaweed flavor
so for our next recipe what we're gonna
do is crispy mushrooms and this is
following the philips airfryer double xl
recipe book that comes with the airfryer
of course
and it's very simple just get your
mushrooms cut it up into slices
dredge them in flour put in the egg
mixture and then dust it off with some
panko bread crumbs and then you'll get
something like this
right so once you do that put it in the
air fryer set the temperature to 180
degrees and the timer two
ten minutes and we'll see how it goes
i'm loving it so
oh wow
gonna do a little bit of a wow
and then pour the rest of the mushrooms
in
oh guys i think you're gonna love this
one
ah making such a mess
right with our crispy mushrooms done
let's uh give it a taste test man all
right so this is our crispy mushrooms
have a try
careful it might be hot i don't know
i um see the smoke coming out of my
mouth
yeah
it's like crispy on the outside and you
can taste the soft chewy mushrooms on
the inside oh
[Music]
okay i'm gonna try one for myself could
go with a dip
pretty much everything that's right
could go over there right yeah special
hand some special sauce oh cool
believe this garlic chili
pop pop
right so what i got in this airfryer is
the same recipe as the crispy mushrooms
but we're using fish instead so we're
kind of making like a fish and chips per
se and again lightly coat them with oil
and don't have to worry too much about
it being greasy or oily at the end of
the cooking process because this
airfryer has a special spiral base that
she collects all the fat and oils so
yeah let's check it out
all right so our fish
on fish and chips
it's done oh look at that golden brown
oh snap
no
gotta play with two lemon wedges let's
scoop out the fish
oh
look at that
look at that
yo
i will use thongs but you know sometimes
being primitive is
a very good thing all right nice and
golden brown i'm gonna sprinkle some
juice off the moon
right there yeah all nice and soaked
yeah
if we do this right when we break the
fish
steam is going to come out so
let's see
if it's um
oh
you go dude
oh wow
oh
let's try it with some tata sauce
punch on the outside
juicy and flaky and inside oh man
wow
all right fellow geeks the final verdict
this is the roasted chicken we followed
the recipe from the philips airfryer
double xl recipe book and uh it took us
about half an hour good half an hour to
45 minutes to cook the uh the chicken
so
it's time
yo
yo
yo
okay
we're gonna fish this baby out
yo
there we go
that's one-sided
he's a chicken right there dude fried
chicken
look at that
very crispy skin
all right and if you take out the onions
you can see all the
juice and everything oh she's still
piping hot
steaming
all right
[Music]
oh my goodness oh
yo
and you can see that um it is crispy
on both sides the top as well as the
bottom right there
damn
nice char going on there it open
yo that is
that
is moist
yo check it out
some juicy stuff man
it's so juicy and tender
that if you twist the drumstick
camera twisting just falls right out of
the bone
okay
yo that that's mad
yo and and then the bone is still piping
hot all right let's let's check out the
breast meat and see how it goes
so we're going to cut right in the
center new
that this
is simply
just juicy
[ __ ] tender
right there look at that
wow
[Applause]
someone said my fire because it's lit
bro
enough of that
i just need five minutes because just
any moment
so the verdict in my opinion about the
phillips airfryer double xl let's start
with the pros you can cook big batches
of food so if you're talking about fries
you don't have to you know put small
little amounts of fries into your
deep fryer and then wait for a second
batch
you could literally plop a whole bag of
fries in it and
it will come out great the downside
regarding the fries it's not as golden
and crispy
as you would have
in a deep fryer
but nonetheless you still get still get
a pretty good decent price
out of it we are talking about a healthy
option here so you know less oil
the food isn't as greasy as it was if
you were to deep fry it i think the
start of the show here is actually the
roasted chicken to kind of have the a
blend between deep-fried and oven-baked
you know that crispy skin the juicy
insides and oh and almost fall to the
bone
but the problem here is that the
underside got a little bit too charred a
little bit of burnt wings over there so
that's something to to take note of as
well so overall the smart sensing
technology is okay i like the fact that
you have a manual function as well
so you're not just fixed onto the
programs that are required here and the
instant heat and rapid airflow
technology does
really make a lot of difference in terms
of cooking time if i were to bake the
same chicken in
in the oven will probably make me take
about
an hour an hour 15 but this was done in
about
40 to 45 minutes so this philips
airfryer double xl is super duper user
friendly and you're really relying on
the machine to just
prompt you when it's done cooking
so considerations the price of course
but you are getting what you're paid for
second round it's huge and if you don't
have the space for it you might not want
to get it other than these features you
know the i i just like how it's a drawer
and you have a handle for it
and it's a huge handle
another cool fact about this is that
it's actually pretty easy to clean it's
actually a three-step process so you can
wash the bucket you can actually take
out the mesh from the
the basket as well as the
container itself all these parts from
here or now are
dishwasher safe so hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you enjoyed it don't
forget to give us a thumbs up and leave
a comment down below whether
this
airfryer is for you or do you have one
and is there any horror stories about
your current airfryer that you don't
like and if you haven't already do
consider subscribing and smash that
notification bell icon so you can stay
updated to our latest reviews unboxings
and geeky tidbits
until then this is zaking signing off
very full
wahoo
you